the sky I wanna lose control I'm ready
to roll
[Music]
feels like I've been walking on ice on
let everything go and feel alright in
the drums and I know we live in money
time we gonna have a good time hands up
to the sky
[Music]
I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday it is
our second to last show of the year here
in 2019 hope you enjoy it hope it's a
good one hope the Auto audio quality's
to your liking I'm feeling very aware of
our audio quality now more than ever
because I listened to half of the Trisha
Paytas jeffree star podcast this morning
and I don't really listen to podcasts so
I find like when people complain about
like other people's audio it's like just
enjoy like stop you can you literally
can't because I was getting so
frustrated with this podcast episode
first of all I don't know where Geoffrey
was it sounded like he was in a
completely other room and the microphone
that Trisha was using like was echoey
and weird it was like I'm dying to hear
this podcast but I have to do it in
installments because it's driving me
nuts wow that's crazy and it actually I
mean I'm it's unfortunate for them but
it makes me feel like a little better
because we're always having audio issues
and I feel like we're the only ones some
time know everyone has audio issues and
it's just like it was shocking okay well
I'm glad we're not alone and it was so
[ __ ] irritating now you know how
people feel you know I do and now
anytime I see a complaint like I will
take it more seriously oh my god it was
so [ __ ] anyway yeah we really do take
it seriously
and I feel like we're all in a good
place I haven't heard anything recent oh
we had um everyone has growing pains
studios but I feel like we're we're fine
yeah we're we're in a good place it's
crazy that it's our second to last show
of the year it won't feel like that for
most of you because after tomorrow's
episode starting on Friday we have five
patreon episodes that we've been
recording all week so like we've been
podcasting back to back to back so it's
our second time show of the year but
like actually our 6 podcast episode this
week right which is so crazy you
actually have some really good episodes
hitting you for next week while we're
gone on vacation you'll be able to keep
up with the toast we have we did another
are you attack here Claudia membership 1
we did our top 10 stories of the decade
so a lot of pop culture stories that we
weren't podcasters for that we finally
got to talk about opportunities not even
alive for know but we were all alive in
this decade
like Kim Kardashian 72 day marriage like
what would have been our thoughts at the
time right so our thoughts have evolved
and you got I wasn't alive to give
thoughts at the time because I would've
had negative things to say of course you
know of course oh well so I'm not sure
if it's a story but um we're also gonna
recap Real Housewives of Orange County
and we're gonna do deer toasters at the
end but can we just quickly did you
include as a story that kkw beauty and
Kylie cosmetics occur slash cutters can
have like their office holiday party
joint together at Nobu last night no I
didn't get a chance to see it it looked
so glam and Kris Jenner gave a speech
like obviously she was crying the whole
time
Matthew was there at her table and he
just looked really sweet I would say
there was probably like 40 people there
I guess that's not like you know I guess
that's just like everyone who works for
all the brands um and Kris was just like
all of you are so important I was
actually really sweet I'm sure as an
employee it was like so nice to be like
seen and heard by Kris Jenner like in
such an intimate setting like that is
how you build like the whale company
morale
yeah you know definitely it was very
interesting the toast holiday party for
you and I okay dinner can't wait also
speaking of patreon we did something
really fun because we know that people
like to give patreon as a gift for the
holidays like a really fun creative gift
it's truly the gift that keeps on giving
like you can give them a year's worth
well you just log in and then you can
cancel it whenever you want so we
thought we'd help you with that and we
created a patreon gift certificate so
that if you are getting that for someone
you can give it in a cute little
presentation I am having like some of
the most rancid breath today like I'm
actually thinking there actually might
be something medically wrong with me
because it's so bad can I have a sip of
your coffee just so now wash things down
I don't know if that helps but that is
like really crazy I wonder what went
wrong for you well I think I slept with
my mouth open and I know that you're
supposed to brush your teeth in the
morning but can we all agree that
brushing your teeth in the morning like
you still have bad breath of course it
doesn't the big thing nobody it helps a
lot yeah
also you know I had a rough-and-tumble
night because Ben is so dramatic Ben
thinks he's the first person to ever get
the common cold so you know what Nicole
just kind of sneaks up on you like we
were watching Orange County last night
and he sneezed and like after that
sneeze he was officially sick you know
and he was just like how is this
happening to me actually I can't some
sort of rare [ __ ] disease I'm like
it's a cold like your nose like go take
a sudafed like what's the [ __ ] deal
he woke up this morning I cannot believe
I'm so sick I'm like it's a cold like
it's just things like so dramatic and if
I'm saying that like you know
it's bad well hopefully you don't get
sick but actually if you do it doesn't
really matter because we're almost done
working for the year [ __ ] it matters I
am not done working I got three big-ass
shows in Chicago this weekend I cannot
get sick thank you for money I'm gonna
pick up some airborne yeah but like you
couldn't get taken like two days no I
literally can't because not only drive
three amazing shows in Chicago Thursday
Friday Saturday night tickets available
girl done job calm even though I'm
pretty sure all three shows are sold out
I think you can get like a rogue ticket
here or there not only dr3 like very
important shows because the Chicago's
teens like pay me also Lord Elizabeth's
gonna be in town so I'm gonna seen her
we're gonna have a night and like I
think she's put some of her home friends
I got to be that cool and healthy it's
not gonna be the TNN holiday party ah
yes oh my god damn I'm not gonna be
there I don't even think I guess we
could throw holiday party for people
besides you and I oh the tannin tannin
like it's it's a nationwide thing you
know right no we would have to have like
a global we have to have like a Google
hangout yeah we're a holiday party
we're worldwide nationwide six six six
six six sixty-six I know everyone has
been waiting with bated breath to see
whether or not I did the tick-tock
roundoff back handspring step-out
roundoff back handspring step-out round
up front handspring full twisting layout
I did it it's on my tick-tock II got
literally no views so if you could head
over my tick-tock girl than a job
I hit 10k followers like I'm really now
like becoming a full-blown tick tock ER
and I'm finding like my passion you know
it's like like with the tan and
Instagram it's like the passion is so
important it's so important to have
passions it's like that's what gets you
out of bed in the morning 1,000%
speaking of passions as you all know TMT
merch is one of my passion and both of
our passions today because we are each
wearing rich not even from the holiday
collection no this is old cropped hoodie
that we restocked I'm wearing the pink
it's available on the site there's a few
left oh I didn't even know that this was
still available also comes in teal I
don't think the teal is available no
there's like a few left over like
honestly if you want one I would go
right now and I'm wearing uh I feel as
though you'd be wearing an XL uh
actually it's a large I can't see okay
well I'll tell you later
um I'm just like and it's so comfortable
it is probably a cropped style but it's
not super crop so you get the illusion
to people that you're wearing a crop
sweatshirt but you're not braving the
unknown my food was covered and that's
all you need to know that is say the
color scheme going on between your shoes
my shoes are stockings and your sweaters
oh and my disgraced Queens t-shirt just
like TBG was wearing yes sir
but this is the Loki one so it's like if
you don't want to say across your chest
that you're a big disgraced Queen like
you can say it in a softer way on your
breast I got ready for about last night
thinking Dallas was on too and it wasn't
and it was just so disappointing cuz I'm
really looking forward to Dallas tonight
is a big night of television Ali was
whatever
I'm sure the reunion will be good what
was in their drinks like they were
acting him like and like no they were
drugged
no David just drunk because she was
coherent
she was just insane I think they were
all roofied totally Steve Lodge put
something in the drink so it looks like
such a excuse me I see such a nice huh
yeah a nice engagement party for like a
19 year old virgin on her first marriage
like yeah who says dress like are you
kidding me yes snd yeah it was out of
control it was out of control for a
third wedding we will recap the season
finale at the end of the episode in
addition to doing to your toasters which
is uh-huh whoo oh my god you're getting
me sick knotting it happen you're right
and think about the audio sniffler
oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry I will Flair's mom
I need to what do you take I need a
drink some orange juice mom I didn't get
some orange juice yeah you need to take
some more and she's for sure yeah and
like airborne for sure not an ADD
transition for airborne you guys know
but you know what's so funny is last
week we spoke so much about master class
that I got like dm's and I saw a bunch
of post in our Facebook group of people
who are like what's the Masterclass
promo code like that wasn't an ad we
were just talking about how it would be
a good gift yeah it is and I didn't use
a promo code so don't tell me what now
or else I'll be truly RDH
I watched a lot of stuff last night that
I want to talk about I know you watched
it too because we had like a group chat
watching party Oh YouTube video Jade's
new YouTube tutorial and Sophia Richie's
makeup tutorial for Vogue and they want
to talk about that one because it stuck
out to me because it changed my life and
all of a sudden like I ordered hundreds
of dollars worth of makeup that she used
and this morning I've actually been in a
rut with my makeup where I haven't been
enjoying putting it on which is like
really new for me that has a lot to do
with your products I love putting on
makeup and this morning I had such a pep
in my step like I think I was a little
bit more beautiful and I started using a
gel cream like Sophia and gelling my
brows up and I think it made a big
difference do not use a Jo like I use a
brow like a gel color but then I used a
clear gel I have the kylie go by brow to
go up and like now my eyebrows are glued
to my face I feel like I'm in shock
tonight
Kylie's brow gel it's [ __ ] super glue
that's crazy good yes I watch the Sofia
one too and I was I also spent $150 at
Sephora on random [ __ ] from both the
Olivia Jade and the Sofia Ricci video
and the Sophia Ricci video was really
good but I just wanted to know like what
foundation she was using because she had
like really blotchy red skin that I've
never seen before
and it's apparent that she has amazing
makeup because her skin always looks
perfect and they didn't [ __ ] say what
she used for what her foundation yes she
said it briefly she uses Becca
Foundation which one I don't know and
then it combines it with some Bobby
Brown mystery serum that was sold out at
Sephora but I couldn't I could barely
even find it at Sephora I loved her
tutorial because from the beginning to
the end she looked different like Oh
show tip makeup teeth what makeup does
and all of these like beautiful
supermodel like celebrity spawn they do
these vogue tutorials in their like I
just used to know a tinted chapstick no
it just makes all the difference are and
they use a bronzer it's like an eye
shadow too and like a brow gel it's like
they use three products in a chapstick
and then it's like a girl on mascara oh
yeah you know it's just so unrealistic
always like a glossy eye highlighter
yeah it's just so unrealistic and it's
like I really don't need to see like
what a perfect person uses makeup for
because I'm not perfect and I use makeup
to look perfect so I don't say it rolled
my eyes at this Sofia Ricci thing at
first Mike what is this perfect [ __ ]
know about anything and then she comes
up without makeup in the comb girls
pimples and she'll take a real person
like different no and then she put on
makeup flawlessly like her makeup looked
amazing her skin looked amazing she has
perfect lips and then the cameo from
Lionel was just excellent excellent we
never get to see her personality yeah
boiler alert she has one a big one she
made me last like a few times I think
she might be a comedian and but like I
don't want to over height because in
watching me like this [ __ ] is invited
but when you go into watching it
expecting nothing because we never hear
from her I was so into it when you go
into watching that when you've watched
past videos of just like supermodels who
don't really need makeup and it's not
kind of a letdown then her video just
over delivers that's why I like the
Kardashians ones too because they wear
so much makeup Rihanna's she was like
you think she's perfect enough like
homegirl like loves to contour her
forehead she had some pimples like she
uses real
[ __ ] makeup and like that was so I
think hers is one of the best ones cuz
he also was like radiation she's now
invented the vogue makeup tutorial
without she said them on the map like
she walked so like Sophia Ricci could
run a hundred percent no one was
interested by them at all until
Rihanna's and then all the card out
actually the Kim one I didn't love she
did like her quick holiday makeup and it
wasn't it wasn't my favorite Kylie's was
everything Kylie's is every honestly I
thought Chloe's was fascinating michio
and I wouldn't expect oh and I forgot
Kourtney do dry with a clean Beauty
talking about her clean beauty app
boring boring but I enjoyed it
no boring but it was probably
interesting to someone yes I'm sure it
was informative and you know there was
an app that gives you like a Q score
about clean Beauty so that's cool cool
I'm happy for her know that I am anyways
check out Sophia Ritchie's and then we
watched a lineage newest makeup tutorial
yes I also bought a few products I
bought that heart-shaped Too Faced
benefit bronzer I'm not benefit to based
I said that already because it looks
great on her she had like a radiant glow
and she said a cheer but it's not
glittery um yeah yeah after Sophia's
that's like all I needed to see um
anyways I think maybe we should get
right into it there's a lot of things
that I like want to talk about along the
way okay but I think it's this would be
a good place to start you know I mean
start at if you think I do think I I
have no opinion on whether or not it's
time cuz that's your job yeah I know I
feel as though it is time for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and it's time for
sure it is time and I don't want to step
on anyone's toes or you know make things
weird you know between us but I would be
remiss devastated and Harper Gooden I
would be suffering from a very very bad
case of rding she can't get sick before
Chicago so don't that is what I'm saying
don't let it happen if I don't let
everyone know the today's episode is
brought to you by ember and ember has
never been more pertinent than it was to
me today because I understand that it's
like four degrees outside but why does
every like Bank restaurant have to be a
sauna
I was ATM for five minutes here and left
with like sweaty underboob it was so
torturous on my team I wish I had my
ember on
or control up in here because
temperature is so personal everyone's
idea of comfortable is unique I prefer
an igloo that is my level of comfort but
I know some people prefer a sauna most
public places heat or cool space is
aiming for temperature that is
comfortable for only 80 percent of the
population
leaving many people thermally undeserved
if you're not feeling thermally
comfortable it can contribute to your
loss of productivity increased stress
level and can be mentally exhausting
although ember wave is not a medical
device for those with medical conditions
raised related to temperature ember wave
can help remedy bursts of temperature
extremes are other uncomfortable
sensations so basically you put an ember
wave around your wrist which is one of
the like since like sensations on your
body like if you are ever feeling hot or
cold and you put something hot or cold
on your wrist it's one of those places
in your body that like can warm up your
whole body like you just sink your wrist
but it's like no it's your hole it's
it's the whole shebang they provide
comfort and unpredictable climates
relief from stress and support for sleep
I am someone who cannot sleep unless it
is a frozen tundra with like every
window open and honestly if you have a
partner let me sleep with someone I'm
with yes I do I sleep and we are just
like on two totally different
wavelengths like then it's a full-blown
furnace in the middle of the night and
like I'm over here dying of heat like I
always wake up sweaty neck and then it's
like if I blow up my hair it's like a
such an ordeal but if you sleep with an
ember it can provide cool bursts
throughout the night mmm some places you
can use ember include your over
air-conditioned office a hot ATM
vestibule restaurants airplanes and
plants I didn't think of that I'm after
work out malls in the car crowded public
spaces and more it was named one of Time
Magazine's best inventions of 2018 and
it has been reviewed by a number of
leading technical publications um it was
invented by three MIT scientists so you
know that it works if you want to get
$50 off your holiday gift of ember go to
ember wave comm slash toast
so ember spelled embr wav e-comm slash
toast
again that's ember wave comm slash toast
embr wav e dot com slash toast to get
$50 off your purchase check it out check
it out sign on get your temperature
right I just got some breaking news that
the snitch is watching oh my god you
really scared me because you're like
tone went like so serious like very
serious never meredith vieira
it's a serious matter I thought you were
like I got some breaking news that's
snitch I don't even know what you're
gonna say don't do that I'm so sorry the
snitches watching you're like one of
those people who screams in a public
place I think I said it very calmly you
were so Stern and scary there is a
special place in hell for people who
scream in public places I will never
forget being in the NYU library oh my
god and then we're back to library after
this I was on the basement floor because
I had to print something before class I
was really quickly like Schmidt sing
wish I had my Ember running around
trying to get something printed and all
of a sudden from a floor above me I
heard a girl shrieks so loud and you
know in this climate especially with
like schools like the whole floor went
dead silent everyone looked around at
each other nobody knew what to do it was
so scary I thought my life was over like
I thought I was so afraid and they been
like nothing happened like ten seconds
later like everyone's like went back on
and there never ended up being anything
happen but like to this day like I hope
terrible things happen to that girl
because you were sent she instilled fear
like serious like fear in the hearts of
many young NYU students and shame on her
wherever she is today I hope she walks
with that guilt in her heart I feel as
though in this climate there should be a
lot of it you're not allowed to scream
and you're not allowed to just start
running oh thank you for reminding me
joggers Jacqui when I see more than one
person running I'm like a what are we
getting from let's go Jackie I will
never forget
thank you I'm bringing up all these
terrible traumatic memories for me I was
walking on my way to up and down a club
that we just be cool and the guy at the
door was such a little prick and now
it's not successful anymore because the
guy was a prick and I was walking up to
me my friend Lilly says she was inside
and I would say I'm like thirty feet
from the door and you know clubs there's
always that crowds outside the crowd
went
sprinting in the other direction like
literally away from the club in all
different directions
sprinting screaming I know J Kevin left
I never found out what happened but like
frightening and I said all this is
everything okay inside check it's cool
that's crazy weird right yeah so I'm
just gonna say like no to the running no
to the running no to the screaming like
even if you're a kid with your friends
like if you're in a quiet like a
restaurant or something and your friend
says something funny you're like yeah
like no okay but that's you so what are
you gonna to jail yourself clear so I
say quiet restaurant so okay
now I feel like that's a great segue
into a story that might not be your
first story but at the AMBER Alert story
no it's not my first story because it
should be no because the news story of
the day is Teresa and Joe Giudice
finally calling it quits it's like not
shocking I guess they have a lot riding
on the trip to Italy that they filmed
her Bravo and apparently it didn't go
well because now they're separated even
though People magazine had a source that
said they are getting two bars but they
they're separating but they have no
intention of getting divorced okay no
I'm not having a lot of bodily functions
are out of control today um I think it's
not shocking because it's like it's time
but it's just I backed that like after
everything that they've been through
it's like actually things are pretty
good now you know they're both flawless
and you know they're like they can visit
each other and like now's when they're
throwing in the towel after everything
that he did to her like she stood by him
and now it was like now he was making up
for it like he spent six months in ice
like trying to do right by the word like
he's really trying to be better and you
don't I mean yeah but I think that even
though there was probably more like
times where they would have gotten
divorce it would have made more sense
but there was so much going on at the
time like and honestly didn't even I
think have the financial resources at
the time till I bring on an attorney
like to get divorced like it actually
makes sense like now that the dust has
settled like they're back in good places
financially emotionally out of prison
physically I think now it makes sense
that they would be getting divorce there
was too much going on between her going
to jail him going to jail so if they
weren't married like they might have had
to testify against each other right so
it actually makes a lot of sense that
like now they're getting divorced Teresa
is just like so far beyond like they're
they're two totally different people now
even that interview for watch happens
live like it was such strangers passing
in the night
yeah he posted a cryptic message to
Instagram he said I broke Chloe
Kardashian of him every next level of
your life will demand a different you
and but ready for a different Joe he is
a different Joe he got his JD he's
starting a business with his friend from
jail like he's a totally different
person he seemed kind of disinterested
in Teresa she seemed totally ambivalent
like I just think it's so time and it's
really sad because they have four kids
together but like this family has been
through worse like right forces I got
the worst thing to ever happen compared
to like your father being deported yeah
and it's just like I feel like gia
Giudice
now is like sort of like me it's like
our parents got divorced like of all the
[ __ ] that's happened to me I'm like I'm
gonna care you know it's like yeah when
I hear people have spirits are getting
dorsum like Oh sad like you're gonna be
fine
you're gonna live so gia Giudice she has
seen the other side this is nothing for
her and Audriana and we were talking
about this yesterday you and I but I
really ship the poor guy Teresa I'm
Geoffrey Catania yeah everyone is saying
like the pool guy just because he's so
hot you knew Teresa and I think he might
be single but someone on watch what
happens live when Dolores was on as the
most person in question and they were
like what would you think of Frank and
Teresa dating because they have a good
relationship he touched her about once
remember they had a lot in common
Frank is very much Teresa's type and
Teresa is very much Frank's type and I
just like completely ship Delores it she
would not be cool with it which I
completely understand that I'm just
gonna have to override in my shipment of
these two I don't ship that hard
honestly because I really ship what
Teresa what Dolores Frankie Tanya and
David have like I think it's a perfect
formula trees in the mix I think it'll
be even more perfect no she's very
radioactive I think she might blow up
this perfect suburban throuple and I
think there's other people out there for
Teresa her pool guy and then she can
also get a free pool
yeah no I'm much I don't ship the pool
guy if anybody makes Oh hands oh he
likes her so much yes anything I just
want like some like 25-year old hunk for
her you know who's not gonna give her
problems
yeah um but I don't know but - Frank
they could go the distance
I think his nice suburban dad from New
Jersey who installs pools is not gonna
give her a problem
I don't know do you think he knows that
he's like become a star I'm sure you're
sure his pool business is booming
booming but I want to see what he does
for Teresa's pool cuz like I would hire
him if I lived in New Jersey Mike the
pool I can't believe that house like has
a lake but doesn't have a pool I just
want to say there's something so shady
about like enormous houses that don't
have pools like it's like you read out
of money queen of Versailles right right
I actually watched my youtube app has
become my absolute favorite place to
spend my time and they now curate videos
that they think I would like on my home
page and I saw Architectural Digest did
I put it in the family tree oh you did
um Danny one watch it now it was
fascinating a twenty two million dollar
townhouse in New York with like three
private terraces it was
sickening five bedrooms 8,000 square
feet two kitchens one entertaining
kitchen one family kitchen it was I need
22 million dollars if you want to get a
mortgage for a twenty two million dollar
house how would she have to put down
like two million maybe four it's the 20
cent that was 20% of 22 1.2 no 42.4
stupid boy I think it's like four
million dollars I don't know I just made
that up
wait 22 it's four point four it's four
point four okay I need to subscribe me
for four point four million dollars
please and I think that that would just
be like so actually let's all go in on
it together put it in your goals oh yes
and it was about today
in the heart of Greenwich Village as the
very dapper kind of obnoxious tour guide
was saying the heart of Greenwich
Village 12th Street 11 east 12th street
so I wouldn't want to live downtown for
22 million dollar townhouse I would but
there's 22 million dollar town oh I've
never seen a house this big and like
ever it was specially engineered for a
rich person it was crazy I ever
encourage everyone to check out the
video is amazing very cool people are
saying that because the pool guy was
Teresa's like high school sweetheart Joe
kind of like came in the way and if they
get back together like it said Nicholas
Sparks movie right Nicholas Sparks movie
with that and then all of a sudden like
the guy the pool guy in this situation
like dies and he donates his heart to
Teresa's son what that was the weirdest
movie I saw no but Teresa did say that
they meant to go to prom together but
change it up going with Joe so it really
could be like you know star-crossed
lovers the Montagues and the Capulets of
New Jersey yeah interesting okay I just
think of the pool they'd have well I
mean this is really exciting because
it's a new leaf for Teresa I'm ready for
a new Teresa on New Jersey because I
understand that like everything that she
does and says must be taken with a grain
of salt but like I'm ready for the
playing field to be even and if she was
still trying to work with Joe while he's
in Italy it's just like it distracts her
from her her job on the show no I feel
like now she still gets to be like I'm
going through a lot because now she's
getting divorced but compared to
everything she went through like a
divorce oh we go through that every day
here at the Real Housewives Academy yeah
but no Teresa will still find a way like
she is gonna be exempt from every
narrative for like a good two years I
don't know I I'm gonna give her one more
season of like passes back this upcoming
season I'll give her the
next season she can still be like
dreaming is interesting because they're
not filming out right now so we might
get so we might start filming when she's
already been divorced or like in the
process of getting divorced for a few
months then and if she has a new
relationship I think I'm never sin my
pass me oh by the way once she's in in a
relationship she is equal like Shannon
beador yep like Shannon beador before
her Shannon storms word which I must
talk about the Duff of it all oh my god
having been on the show like multiple
times I was really crazy kissing her on
the lips disgusting like I could die
that was so crazy so weird okay next up
these stars are making a million dollars
per episode right now oh yes some
website variety released a list of the
biggest moneymakers in TVs this time II
love about the end of the year 1 million
dollars an episode kind of money Reese
Witherspoon Kerry Washington Steve
Carell John four Aniston Nicole Kidman
and more round out the list of this
year's top TV earners and the writing's
on the wall there has never been a
better time to be on TV there has never
been a better time to be a woman in TV 2
because Jennifer Aniston and Reese
Witherspoon are making 2 million dollars
in episode on the morning show the
morning show and when you read the
numbers it's like damn streaming is
where it's at like even HBO like you
can't compare no you can't compare I
think that they are worth the money but
then I always saw something that was
like they spent like three hundred
million dollars to make the morning show
and it's like is it gonna there's no way
that a show can even a successful show
can make you 300 million dollars right
does that mean they got 300 million
dollars worth of Apple plus
subscriptions I don't know they actually
got mine just cuz I wanted to watch that
show so maybe it's working good for them
there I mean if anyone's worth it the
two of them are yeah but 300 million
dollars for one season of the TV shows
out of control and it's like the
production it's a film and it's a
morning show they have a set like it's
not so crazy it's not right the future
or not dynasty it's not the warning
toast
wait that's so silly like I feel like
the streaming platforms are so out of
control with their budgets like even I
on that list it was um included a bunch
of comedy specials and they said Ellen
got paid around 45 million dollars for
her one-hour special 20 to 25 million
dollars 20 to 25 million dollars for him
one-hour special
relatable which I did watch and found to
be incredibly silly and stupid and like
she brought down a projector and like
was using did
elements like you're one of the world's
most famous comedians and like you need
to protect her to help you like it was
so silly to me that seems like a
weight's like I just don't believe that
Ellen's
special generated even close to 25
million dollars yeah I mean a lot of
these Truman's new services are
investing they're like planting the
seeds and then you know the growth
they're not making the money back yet
but they're there and you know it
oh I think we were talking about this
like two years ago I don't Netflix so
spending so much money and people are
like they're gonna go bus but they
invested so much in their own content
and now like other networks are starting
their own streaming service so they're
losing an unoriginal content like
friends and stuff yeah and so they have
to be making their own something I think
it is gonna pay off for at least for
Netflix yeah I just feel I feel it's
definitely case-by-case and I'm sure
they would never release but I'd love to
know whose specials got watched and
whose did it
like honestly I heard Jerry Seinfeld get
paid for two specials like I haven't
seen either of them maybe they don't
come out yet but Dave Chappelle got 60
million dollars for one special and like
it was the it was the talk of the
culture like it was so you know
important whether you liked it or not
like everyone was talking about it yeah
to me that is a great usage or 60
million dollars but two specials Jerry
Seinfeld $100,000,000 I haven't even
heard about them yet maybe they haven't
come out yet I don't know but to me like
that doesn't seem like a good a mess man
I don't know I guess time will tell yeah
time will tell I would love to hear Amy
Schumer's you know she was one of the
highest-paid women yeah I think was 11
million dollars yeah so I'd love to know
like if people like that because I
actually watched it I thought the first
30 minutes were excellent I thought the
second three minutes were just like not
it but it was decent but I think overall
that's considered a success
Millie Bobby Brown makes three hundred
fifty thousand dollars per episode of
strange orphan child which is great and
then Reese Witherspoon and Nicole Kidman
are now making a million dollars for
season two a big little lies so it's
it's a great time to be Reese
Witherspoon Oh Reese Witherspoon raking
it in Oh also they had something on
there Nicole Kidman is on another show
that I'd never heard of like an Amazon
or like a Hulu show nine perfect
strangers yet how much you making for
that Richard um a million damn at least
a million Keith Urban living the life
who do you think makes my running Nicole
Kidman or Keith Urban me depends on the
year yeah if it's like an Oscar a year
or if it's a an album year right is it a
Stepford Wives and it's
so like it takes a lot of time to get
paid for songs oh yeah I think you only
get paid twice a year for a song yeah
that's crazy so I think it's just like a
year-by-year situation we don't watch
but they announced the winner of the the
boys this cutie he looks like Luke
Holmes with brown hair and Luke Holmes
performed on the finale oh he's pretty
much like they were spoiling it you know
perfect he's saying even though I'm
leaving and did a sensational job oh I
gotta check it out and then all the the
judges went to Chrissy Teigen and John
Legend's house I shot on Twitter she was
freaking out because she didn't know
that they were all coming from The Voice
finale and if they she knew she would
have gotten a cake and she didn't have a
cake and then someone found a video from
someone's Instagram story of Chrissy
Teigen being at one of the tapings of
The Voice last week and going up to when
Stefani and John and John was like by
the way they're all coming over next
week and Chrissy didn't hear because she
was talking to when Stefani so he
actually did tell her ever since her QA
about being a celebrity I followed her
on Twitter which is how I know all this
dumb stuff and it's an a very premium
experience like I can't recommend it
enough so it is a great question have
you gotten paid for toastie at your song
you know that is an excellent question
one in which I actually thought about
yesterday when filing my gear in taxes
um so I get because I'm not on a record
label you have to use like a third party
for like independent artists I'm very
independent and alternative you are um
and so they get your song onto streaming
platforms and they're the ones
responsible for paying you so I don't
know like that's a good question I get I
get um monthly income reports like being
like how many people streamed it how
many people bought it on iTunes this
month um so feel free to stream and buy
it on iTunes toast by claudius right but
I haven't actually gotten a check I once
heard from a prestigious songwriter that
um it takes two years i'ma gonna blow up
her spot takes two years to get paid for
a song hmm well then that would make
sense so will will ask you that question
in two years I really for our next story
no I'm not because I want to talk about
something that happened to yesterday I
governor Cox and you know I took all the
stuff and like threw it in different
parts of my shower bathroom kitchen
vanity and I was in the bath last night
and I had literally like the gnarliest
like patches of spray tan like all over
my body especially my neck and I
remembered I had got in my Birchbox this
exfoliater that you put on your hand did
you yeah and actually I'm experiencing
the same experiencing the same spray-tan
issue as you and that's a great idea
it's incredible and then I bought like
full-sized a whole variety pack because
you can do that once you get something
from birch pots so we I'm by the way I
only started subscribing to birch box
I've obviously heard of birch box before
but once they became a sponsor I like
start to get to get a monthly thing and
it is so worth the money like I can't
believe that I and I'm not even just
being like you know like for the ad I
can't believe that I haven't been
subscribing to birch let my whole life
it is such a it's a joy it's a joy it's
a gift from you to you it's such a
surprise it's such fun and like for all
we're all like beauty lovers it's so
much fun to discover new products bird
spots is so onset awesome it's a monthly
box of you time aperture a majority of
the population knows that even just a
few minutes of you time can make a world
of difference almost it feels like you
really have time for yourself these days
every month you can get your birch box
it's a reminder that you deserve you
time to take care of yourself and to
make whatever time you have for your
beauty and grooming routine even if it's
five minutes a moment that's about you
and for you it is the best way to buy
beauty and grooming items it is a
monthly box of beauty and grooming
samples that are personalized to your
beauty and grooming profile making it
easier to discover products that are
right for you
for many you can be intimidating to walk
into a huge beauty store and be faced
with an overwhelming amount of choices
and you just don't have time with
Birchbox you can get curated deluxe
sized sample so it's not tiny like one
drop it's a pretty sizable travel size
amount then you can try at your own
place in the comfort of your own home
when you find something you love you
could just buy a number it's box calm it
gets delivered to your door convenient
and something to look forward to getting
in the mail every month it's like
sending yourself a surprise gift for
just 15 dollars every month it's an
accessible and convenient way to
discover new skincare haircare and
makeup products it's not just makeup I
got that exfoliator I think that brand
was called daily care or something it
was amazing the samples come to you our
personalized been paired with helpful
information about each product and how
to use it filling out your beauty and
grooming profile is quick and easy
you'll answer questions about your skin
and hair type of preferences and
lifestyle the Birchbox online shop
features products for more than 500
prestigious brands mac Benefit tart
wander Beauty that was the mascara that
we got this month that everyone said is
like the world's best mascara
Kiehl's sundae Riley or
Bay and living proof head to Birchbox
comm slash TMT and use the code toast 15
for 15% off your subscription head to
birch box comm slash TMT and use the
code toast 15 for 15% of subscriptions
it is great to get for yourself or as a
gift I highly recommend it this great
gift idea yeah Margo like when she was
in high school her friends got her a
year subscription of Birchbox it was
such a cute idea like you used to come
to her little apartment I just have so
precious also I'm going away at the end
of the week and this is the first time
I'm not stressing about like shampoo and
conditioner and putting them into like
little travel-size bottles because I
have all this stuff from immersed foxes
that are perfect for to take you with
you for traveling less than three fluid
ounces okay our next story Northwest was
photoshopped into the Kardashian family
holiday card if you notice there was
something off about Kim kardashian-west
family holiday cards were right on track
I didn't notice anything I didn't notice
anything because I'm not a loser
and I have a wife the adorable Christmas
card which featured Kim has been Kanye
and children North psalm Chicago and st.
was the picture of cozy it featured the
family clad in cream and grey sweats
sitting on a set of stairs with a
grinning scene and a perfectly true
bokura she was so cute there's they're
all so cute there was just one problem
with North's appearance it was
photoshopped in on a recent appearance
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show Kim admitted
that her eldest daughter had actually
been added to the card as part of a
composite after refusing to participate
in the photo shoot you know what's so
funny is I read this on Twitter and like
the narrative of the Twitter moment was
like after fans are dying to know if
North was photoshopped in I'm like I
didn't see anyone thinking that she was
photoshopped in I didn't see the
comments in the toasters and the
toasters no [ __ ] everything I didn't
even see any tweets I just thought it
was like a nice thing and I just hate
that like people on Twitter like take
credit for everything you know yeah I
know she's just offering up this
information no one was accusing her of
anything and North's even knowing that
she was photoshopped in I still can't
see it anything to me st. looks like he
was yes he's brighter and more chill
Rubik than everyone and he's on a
totally different set so he could have
just been placed there whenever I
thought the same thing but honestly like
North being the relatable Queen that we
know and love she was having a day so
quote she refused to be in the shoot she
was just crying because she wanted her
specific hairstyle whatever North
insisted she'd rather not take part in
the
holiday moment so Kim resigned herself
to her corner evil not appearing in the
photo I said fine you're not gonna be in
the card that's the decision you're not
gonna be in the card I'm just going to
take the family card without you and she
was fine with that oh my god I can't
she's turning into a monster
the next day she woke up and was like
mommy I really want to do a card and
when you're the daughter of Kim and
Kanye you get what you want
those are made for an impromptu photo
shoot to incorporate North into the card
thank God the photographer was still in
town she said I just want a photo shoot
with just you so I said perfect I called
the photographer I had her come over I
said I have no makeup on now I look
totally different let's just pretend
shoot us but cut me out and you'll
photoshop her in I mean honestly like I
feel like in parenting 101 this is
exactly what you're not supposed to do
but the Christmas card is so important
to Kim and I feel like every year
becomes harder and harder for her just
to like get this [ __ ] Christmas you
know their own kids it's a yeah even
have job right then off schedule so job
things they're passionate about like
this is Kim schedules you can't even get
the kids in the car I'm really curious
if they're gonna do a full family photo
shoot because last year that they aren't
either I think Kim actually gave up on
it because she was like the only one
trying to make it work her and Chloe but
like the kid was one spearheading it and
it came so hard and it started so many
fights and like nobody was even
appreciative of that special family
moment and I think they're not gonna do
it this year and really regret it ya
know and by the way that was two years
ago that weird holiday card where they
release take one picture every of all
the kids um no one Jean when they had it
on the show that was for the card two
years ago so did they do one last year I
don't think so I don't remember one why
can't they just all just take a group
photo at the holiday party right like
some where they're all at right it
shouldn't be that hard no it really
shouldn't be um but it's stressing me
out for them but we never did like a
yearly family photo so maybe it's more
stress than we realize it is for sure
but like I don't know I'm glad they got
it I'm actually did one this year and it
was really stressful incredibly oh my
god I was so [ __ ] hot um
Kim's appearance on ellen though was
riddled with interesting factoids
because she addressed a lot of things
all shows Ellen's 12 days of giveaway so
everyone in the audience got like a full
wardrobe of skims a full kkw beauty
collection and a pair of Yeezys like she
did the k'kaw VA and skins and then like
her phone fake rang she was like hi Deb
you know I'm a-tellin right now the 12
days of giveaway oh you are okay bye
and then Ellen was like what was up
and she was like oh you know Connie has
like this little like sneaker line like
with the dds and the audience like went
wild then she pulled out a box she's
like everyone's getting easy through
bizzy's and it was really cute that's
really cute and for some reason chrissy
teigen was there too i didn't understand
that part but she also addressed on
Ellen the James Corden of it all where
kendall ranked all the parents what did
she say so Kim was like it's such a
tough position to me and like I had to
do fill your guts once um and I know I
wasn't mad or anything I think Courtney
was take such pride in being a parent
and she's an amazing parent is what Kim
said but I think she was definitely hurt
by it and honestly and then Kim was like
honestly like she should have just eaten
something like I ate like bull sperm so
I didn't have to admit that Khloe and
Kylie were both pregnant at the time
she's like I just did it like you take
one for the team and she was like so I
think if anything they were upset that
she didn't just cover for them instead
she answered the question like selfishly
no but like if they went through the
whole thing
Kendall and Harry and not one of them
answered a question oh yeah someone has
to answer that is true and you know you
can't say that your sisters are pregnant
like you you can yeah but you can do a
ranking that like you could make up in
your head it's um it's not like you're
stating facts yeah and then I didn't
even realize I guess she said Kylie
second to last who did she say she went
Rob Chloe Kim Kylie Kourtney Kylie Kim
Kourtney um Kim Kylie Kourtney oh so
obviously Kim wasn't mad like that's not
it's not yeah but they're all really
good parents like none of them are out
here like beating their kids like it's
so silly yeah but but that's the thing
Kourtney would get mad at and that's
what Kim said I know I if whoever was
dead last should has every right to get
mad but I don't think it means that
Kendall shouldn't have answered the
question on patreon yesterday we were
talking about the Ellen of it all like
we never know how to feel about her like
is she the devil or is she actually an
angel like there's so many rumors better
she's just so much good philanthropy
like helps people all the time then you
also hear she's like literally the most
evil woman on the planet
um but her relationship with the
Kardashians is so deep and so like they
trust her so much like that's the only
daytime like real press they ever do is
they go on Ellen all the time like
multiple times a year so it has to make
me think like she's a cool girl yeah
like if the Kardashians approve like she
has to be cool maybe it just depends who
you are face them what house what what
you can offer Ellen you know yeah
okay next story an update from yesterday
when we got an Amber Alert
a girl staged a terrifying kidnapping
caught on surveillance footage police
sources are all got amber alerts about a
girl in the Bronx and then there was a
surveillance video of four men pulling
up in a car and grabbing her off the
street it was the most terrifying
terrifying video everyone literally like
everyone in New York everyone on Twitter
was like so taken by this video like
everyone was just like shook and it
became such a worldwide story and an
hour in an hour and then later in the
night they found her it's like holy [ __ ]
alive you never find someone alive like
oh my god what a great gift
then she admitted to staging it because
she was mad at her mom for being quote
overprotective are you [ __ ] kidding
me I can't no no not only I can't I
shan't
and I can't and I refuse no I absolutely
refuse I refuse to participate I would
be remiss if i did this is so [ __ ] up
on so many different levels what is the
crime here not only did you waste police
resources but like we all got
emotionally involved in your story and
you wasted my [ __ ] day yeah where do
I get my day back is there is there jail
time for taking someone's day no but
it's just it's such an unethical thing
to do like if you want to run away from
home just pack up eyes we all did it as
kids you took a little pillowcase and
put your toothbrush in and you ran down
the block he ran to the front of the
lawn
yeah you're into the stop side go run to
the stop sign homegirl this is so uncool
like this is musty smell yes a sommelier
of course and so I guess there is no
patricians I think Jessie smell that
thing like really went quietly like into
the night and I don't want to stop
talking about it
I actually spread a story today I didn't
read the story but I saw the headline
that he might be back on Empire what you
no no pull it up because he was never
actually it yeah technically he didn't
commit a crime he wasn't charged with
anything until proven guilty and he was
not proven guilty and even though like
the majority of the world like knows
that he did fake this thing in a court
of law
he didn't technically do anything wrong
so he shouldn't he could actually sue
for wrongful termination yes here's what
it says Jesse Smollett could return for
Empire finale says showrunner just a
finale okay
yeah I guess cuz he's part of the
casting you know he wasn't charged with
anything right like it's just it's a
weird place to be and it's kind of like
um Oh Jay Simpson you know it's like we
know you did it but technically you
didn't right you know exactly well like
Casey after they you know technically
she's a free woman like she can do
anything around but you killed your
[ __ ] good right it's weird you know
it's weird when law and like Fame
interact it is
so excited to get to talk in okay did
the final story I thought was just does
your belly just growl yes
it's silly I bet that the microphone
picked it up you know what I think it's
because I mean I know it's because I'm
hungry I would assume because last night
I was just having like dinner misfortune
when I went to order something on post
meat and it canceled on me because like
they weren't open I guess then I ordered
something else something nearby because
I was it was almost 8 o'clock and I'm
doing intermittent fasting and about an
hour later I was like where's my food I
tried to order from a quick place I
realized I didn't place the order but
then it was 9 o'clock
oh I just had to have a yogurt and I
just found is the most devastating thing
oh my god
I had a not anything crazy I had an hour
in 10 minutes took me to get my sushi I
was really annoyed but in order for
chicken from sushi sake oh my god it's
so good to meet sushi no from sushi
sushi and so um I ate so fast like you
know when you just can't get the food
into your stomach I ate in a record time
like literally he was shocking I was
sick the whole night for meetings oh my
god it was horrible that is interesting
I got to eat like a piece and now I'm
like so skinny because I literally had
so much diarrhea so simple math simple
math I know everyone's like on the
comments we know Matt called he looks
like so snatch today it's cuz I diarrhea
oh you like diarrhea
ok they can final story a little sign of
the times news just stop your crying
into the side of the time ok so here's
what the teens are up to are you ready
for it
yeah what's marker doing if she's not
even a team in my eyes she is a teen um
st. because she's of a different
generation federal data shows a
significant increase in the number of
high school students vaping marijuana
and news
Cannabis every day on the other hand
though alcohol and opioid use is way
down among teens that's good so there's
something we need and Julie more there
yet there Julianne they're vaping
marijuana
what are marijuana tablets but they're
drinking less and not doing opioids
great you know what it's like kids are
always gonna be doing something right so
like I guess it's good they're not doing
opioids remember there was a time when
heroin was like rampant in New Jersey
because it was cheaper than weed mm-hmm
like at least we're not in that phase of
our lives like if the worst thing these
kids are doing like smoking some pot or
ripping a jewel like is it that bad and
the kids are always gonna be doing
something right and they tell you
they're drinking alcohol and then like
being so steep dying of alcohol
poisoning and like a little drunk
driving a car like idiots so honestly
you want to sit in your house in the
basement and smoke pot and like a ripple
and think you're cool and put it on your
close friends story like I'm fine with
that I really don't think this is so bad
no it's just it's just an interesting
factoid that I found to be interesting
and like if you read this story I'm like
you're a loser II like concerned mother
like okay this is bad but as someone
who's like realistic and like went to
school with kids who are doing way worse
like if back in the day the craziest kid
in our school was just like smoking pot
and had a jewel like crazy crazy like I
think this is actually a step in the
right tracks yeah like back in the day
the kids were smoking cigarettes in high
school oh yeah like literally like
outside by the quad and though drooling
isn't good for you it's better than
segre and they were forgetting their
cranberry CDs out in the squad
right because they were like so busy
trying to snatch up other cigarettes
right before the snitch came things max
nothing
yeah like Heather Mooney in the back of
the building meeting the man with the
cowboy hat but I do think that this
trend is going to change because the
snatcher is such a trendsetter and like
she's been smoking cigs so I think
everyone will eventually revert to
smoking cigarettes classic classic stuff
okay the fast eye stories I think I
think we really covered those robust and
you know what tomorrow's show is gonna
be the top 5 stories of the year so this
is really like the last show with the
news of the day so let's recap Real
Housewives of Orange County let's do it
she wrote down some notes because that
is wanted resolution because I want to
get better at remembering things I
wanted to say Susan finale we had Vicki
and Brooks and Vicki and Steve's
engagement party thrown by Tamra and
Shannon would have loved to know who
paid for it because it did seem quite
lavish it did it was
cater there was like staff handing out
food there's a full Pinterest budget
that buffet looks so good especially wet
after I forgot to order my dinner oh my
god I was looking on it I was like I
gotta get to this party
seeing TV see food on TV when you are so
[ __ ] hungry legume Kapoor is though
there was just something about that
buffet yeah that was grumpiest yeah
there was like a salad that looked
delicious that chicken everyone showed
up including Kelly excuse me I'm so
sorry to the podcasters today um what
happened before oh Emily found out she
needs a hip replacement when he said
that I was shook like that is no small
feat my own and he said you have a high
threshold for pain but according to the
end of the episode that she got the hip
work yes so I think on the I may be on
the reunion will she have gotten it yet
probably I wonder I hope so I'm she's
doing okay and he said it's gonna change
her life you're gonna feel amazing um
this episode was really trance I mean
I've been really liking Emily I've never
disliked her maybe that's not true but
you weren't like in love with her you
know and I'm and I'm getting like I'm
really enjoying her she said something
so funny that was just like an
off-the-cuff thing I mean she was just
talking about how like she's had the
worst year of her life yeah but she's a
survivor and she's determined to make it
better and my husband's gonna be nice to
me and he's gonna be a good husband and
it's like like she's so sadly self-aware
you know I had saw something in Emily
Simpson last season and I'm so glad that
like I was right because tort-like I
feel like she really fell into like her
role by the end and Sharon Vicki I been
fighting on Twitter basically she was
saying that like Vicki contacted
everyone at the beginning of the season
to turn on Kelly so we can finally get
Kelly off the show and like I guess
Emily like toyed with the idea because
she just wants to be on the show and she
doesn't know Kelly really that well and
I guess over the course of the season
she just like did what she felt like was
right like she took the side that she
thought the that justice should be on
and she her and Kelly are like so best
friends like they've been like tweeting
pictures of each other like they're
really cute
and as much as like again I can't
justify Kelly's actions like when she
yelled at Bronwyn calling her dumb like
that's the exact reason that you can't
really ever get fully behind Kelly but
it's like the double standard is out of
control like I can't say this loud
enough
Kelly is not suing Tamra and Shannon Jim
Bellino is so as much as it was [ __ ]
up that Kelly made that Instagram
comment Tamra isn't paying 300 thousand
dollars because of the Instagram comment
uh throughout the up
so I they were making it seem and I
started to believe that Tamara was
paying more because like Kelly provided
Jim with like some sort of proof or
something that was making the case more
- she did it but Shannon was on watch
what happens live and she explained it
in a way that I completely understand
except for out in the rules of Real
Housewives it doesn't work exactly she
was saying Kelly was my close close
friend we had conversations on the phone
crying about this lawsuit
Kelly was crying with me like which she
was a friend like that and for her to
just go to the other side one day and
say hey how can I help like I don't want
to be friends with someone like that and
if she go to Jim Bellino and all for her
help yes what a date is that she
messaged Jim Bellino and like oh and oh
like okay I don't know if she provided
help it doesn't according to what Emily
said in the show and her confessional
she was like Kelly's not being deposed
like Kelly's not a part of this right
Ellie's not adding anything but I think
to Shannon it was just like if say I
have a best friend I'm in a fight with
like a mortal enemy and I vesser knows
this and just one day we have a
disagreement my best friend goes my
mortal enemy he's like hey count can I
help I will never [ __ ] speak to you
again by the way 1000% and by the way if
if it's just the Instagram comment then
Tamra and Shannon are completely
overreacting but if she actually
contacted Jim Bellino they're like
that's a whole other level but they
didn't say in the show that she did that
yeah I guess maybe the tweet is like
when she was she tweeted at you Melina
like you're roaming to his side yeah if
that's the only thing she did like they
definitely overreacted last night they
just have no they shouldn't be friends
with Kelly because that's an incredibly
[ __ ] up thing to do yeah but like her
blaming Tamara blaming Kelly for writing
a three hundred thousand dollar check
was completely because where's that
comment she had to write the check right
it was so silly and honestly Gina who's
like so far up the three amigas his ass
was actually being quite reasonable baby
girl that's my girl by the way we're
seeing each other you're seeing Emma
lately I've seen Gina it's just crazy
that like I've become the Gina defender
but it's like I don't even like her but
like she's becoming more self-aware
talking about her hair oh my god her
hair and I just think I like her
confessionals I don't know something
about her I just think she's real i I
don't know okay but when she was like
jog with Bronwyn and shot me like oh
yeah I guess not is so drunk so drunk
that you I swear I think they were
drugged all
everyone was so [ __ ] up except Leakey
yeah
but she was like it just so happened
when Shannon's hair caught on fire oh my
god I rewind it because I didn't see I
thought I saw it happening I realized
that they zoomed in on it but I was just
like - out of like my in my own head and
then I rewinds it I was like holy [ __ ]
she lost a good chunk err yeah but I
think they were extensions I thought
though if you put alcohol on hair like
it makes it worse it's a llama bull
horse it was the worst thing she could
have done I think just like the capping
got it out no when when she finally took
her hair out of the fire and whipped it
onto her jacket the fire went out
immediately
yeah but then Vicky was so dramatic
flowing tequila on it yeah I thought I
was like my whole life I thought you
couldn't like use like if you're
drinking wine in someone's haircut
somebody like don't throw it it's
flammable no don't throw alcohol oh yeah
you could throw water on and it was like
when you pour wine into like a pasta it
like blows up right but you could throw
water on it yeah of course but I think
there was any water around cuz obviously
nobody was drinking water no no one was
drinking water
I hope Bronwyn and Kelly are cool
because like I think they had like a
good friendship Kelly was just Kelly was
in a lot of ways last night very
composed and calm and collected
especially when it came to Vicki but
then like turning on and just snapping
at Bronwyn was so mean yeah it was Nina
I think I think it's thought they should
be fine I'm not saying that based on
anything that I've seen like that
Brahmin invited all the girls to her
birthday party the next like a couple
months yeah I think that that's like
textbook Kelly just like overreacting on
a small thing and that's what she needs
to get better at but I think that can be
forgiven yeah it was just disappointing
it was disappointing because Bronwyn was
just like talking it was like the same
way how Kelly was just I mean Tamara was
just like screaming at Gina and Gina was
just like listening and then she was
getting mad at Gina Gina listen that was
crazy we lost you running around into
the bushes it was so crazy something
happened maybe they were just like it
there all day cuz they put on the party
I don't even know like but the beginning
of the party looks like it was on the
side of the road um yeah but they were
just like pulling up and like having
hearings right there yeah it was cute it
was a cute party yeah I thought it was
really nice I would just love to unpaid
for it I think Vicki probably paid for
it was that expensive a open bar fully
catered they rented out the whole space
a lot of people like and then actually
like cute even it wasn't my style they
had a lot of take or like that she
defensively we ever got the chandelier I
think Viki paid for it yeah me too I
just gave them the money but like
pretend like they threw it for her just
like they planned it yeah interesting
I'm excited for tonight's reunion I know
I'm loving that and we also get to see
the finale of Dallas where Leeanne will
finally come to terms with her
incredibly racist remarks
hopefully we'll get some insight into
what we're going to what's going to
happen to her yeah you know I think
it'll all depend on how she handles it
at the Reunion yeah of course that'll
like and I think Bravo's probably
waiting to see how people react to it
right based on what she has to say yes
she apologizes if she defends herself
there's nothing worse than being wrong
and like taking your heels in on your
wrongness yeah but I I think if she were
to apologize I mean in a real unreal way
in a real way I I think that people are
forgiving I think I can forgive her
right so I think it'll all just depend
on how it all plays out and then we
would hear a decision yeah I just want
Kerry to make her Instagram bio chirpy
Mexican like that would just like she
would win you know yeah okay let's do
your toaster I pick two
brought to you by vistaprint the most
important time is now the important of
feeling professional polished and
prepared when it counts is right now for
small business owners or people like us
who produce certain podcast being
plugged in and prepared when an
opportunity comes is crucial those
moments happen all the time and they're
happening right now having a business
card that shows how professional you are
in your pocket ready to hand out is the
first step to making something happen
your next big opportunity is coming
right now
and we're here to help you own the now
with free shipping on any business card
in any quantity choose whatever style
finish shape or paper you like and get
free shipping and because you can pick
the colors fonts design and images it
means that you can create something as
unique and compelling as your business
if you're ready to get started on your
business card it's super easy plug your
information and logo into hundreds of
fresh designs tailored to your type of
company or upload your own layout pick
the paper stock style and quantity
that's right for you and you can even
upgrade to unique touch like rounded
corners order and receive your cards
with free economy shipping so as if you
needed any more reason to choose
vistaprint you can feel good knowing
that vistaprint uses only carefully
selected inks and reasonably sourced
paper stocks your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or your money back
they'll make it right this different
wants you to be able to own the now in
any situation which is why our listeners
will get free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity just go to
vistaprint.com and
the promo code toast and you'll
automatically get free shipping on
business cards any style any quantity
it's a limited time offer though so only
now at vistaprint.com
promo code toast let's jump in to your
desserts this is titled
my neighbors sex and her vocal dog tier
toasters please don't share my name I am
afraid of my neighbor recently I had a
new woman move into the apartment next
door
one of the first things she said to me
was it nice to meet you face-to-face now
you know the person behind the noise
complaint still want a file against me
so like not a great start anyways she
hasn't disappointed in the nose noise
department my building is set up to
reduce noise half of our shared wall is
her balcony and the other half is our
kitchen back to back but she has the
noisiest dog in the loudest music I
think she works from home most days as
do i and she plays music 24/7 when she's
home except sleeping the music is just
loud it's just loud enough in my
apartment that can hear it consistently
but not loud enough that it's if she's
having a party slash bumping so it's an
awkward amount to call the front desk
and file an always complain for more
than her music though is her sex I don't
care if she wants to get laid power to
the pus get a girl but her dog barks the
entire time she's having sex at max
volume how do I know she's having sex
during that time because moments after
the dog stops barking a guy is always
leaving or he leaves a little while
after also it has been confirmed by an
unnamed source in this case oh it's been
confirmed by an unnamed source in case
this woman is a toaster also sometimes
above the dog barking you can hear what
our 100% sex noises loud ones as a note
there aren't just at night evening time
sometimes in the morning or in the
middle of the day the other night it was
10:00 p.m. p.m. on a monday and her
music was blaring louder than normal and
her dog barking super loud for a full
hour
it's so mentally taxing to listen to a
dog bark that loud for so long I have my
own dog luckily he doesn't bark back but
it definitely disrupts him I'm really at
a loss for what to do it with the music
and barking during sex has become such a
headache for me do I knock every time
it's happening no when she can't come to
the door because she's busy this has
already happened on occasions where I
knock for 5 minutes and no one comes
even though she's in there do I start
Farley noise complaints until management
realizes the frequency my building isn't
the fastest out reacting to noise
complaints so by the time they come up
she could be done and the dog done
barking do I have a convert conversation
with her about it it for reference such
background I'm 23 year old living 23 23
years old and she's in her mid to late
we live in a luxury apartment building
we run into each other in the hallway or
walking our dogs often often enough that
if I say something it could be awkward
please help I truly don't know what to
do a happy camper that needs her
counselors help PS I'm excited for the
Chicago Show Claudia and I'm so so
excited woohoo
this is really weird and I don't really
think that there's much that you can do
because you could file Illinois skin
clean chair but like what is she
supposed to do stop having sex like she
can't control that her dog is barking I
don't know what size dog she has like
maybe the dog she could know to put the
dog in another room but it's like that
requires some a building's not gonna say
we know that well you have sex your dog
is barking could you place your dog in
another room while you have sex like and
I don't think going through the
legitimate channels will really do
anything that aside from the music
blasting but that doesn't seem to be the
problem um I totally disagree you live
in a luxury apartment like you're paying
a premium program like this is torture
and part of living in an apartment
building is being a part of a community
and being a considerate neighbor like in
a house like you own that house you rent
that house like that is your land you
can do with it what you want you're in
an apartment building like you are a
part of a community and the way that the
community runs properly is everyone is
considerate and if you're paying a price
for an apartment and you're being
tortured working from I'm not only is it
in your apartment it's you work you
[ __ ] do something whether it's go
through the proper channels I don't give
a [ __ ] so it's gonna be awkward when you
walk your dog you got ellipsis like
between the music the dog I'm sorry if
your dog is barking because you're
having sex like how does your dog know
you're having sex like figure it out
when Theo barks I'm like literally
mortified he never barks when he does my
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] like yeah you
take care of it that's part of being a
dog owner like that dog is your
responsibility I totally disagreed you
like take care of it whether it's being
annoying like I complained once about
something in my building and I know the
guy thought I was doing like I don't
care yeah I live here I think I don't I
agree it's you where you live but it's
also where she lives and she can do what
she wants in her apartment the dog
barking she's got to get that [ __ ] under
control um but I don't know like I don't
have a dog so I don't know what she
could do think of how bad it has to be
if the building is built to like if you
only share a wall with her kitchen and
your other wall is her balcony like I
shouldn't be hearing anything unless
she's [ __ ] in the kitchen right you
know okay so I mean definitely start
with the building and letting them know
what's going on maybe they can make it
better if it doesn't get better just say
something to her and the fact that she
was like so facetious but her memory
doesn't even know I love a note I left a
sticky note on the door once and then it
could be anyone on the floor yeah except
I live in a building with only three
apartments on every floor and one of
them is in office so it was obviously me
giving it to the other one and I left
the sticky note on his door and like it
never got and I don't actually don't
know what he looks like I've never seen
him I think he's a part-time tenant and
the sticky note was like on the door for
like a week and I was an elevator and I
got out and someone got out with me and
he went into the apartment this too you
know I [ __ ] ran into my apartment so
[ __ ] bad I saw him like a look at the
stick and I would be like mm-hmm I just
basically was like it smells stop
whatever I'm like such like a like a
little [ __ ] starter in my building
totally yeah uh yeah okay so do it do
what you got to do but this sucks
sorry um this is another one called the
nose job edition hi girls I just want to
start at least canceling headphones for
while you work that's what it's like why
is it on this girl like to [ __ ] now
go out of pocket to get expensive pair
of headphones which shouldn't let's
rebuild when other people just like
can't be civilized human beings I don't
know that it's uncivilized it is part of
living in an apartment building is it a
dog barking is something and in an
apartment building like that is
something that is a concern so complain
about the dog barking I mean you can't
really complain about someone having sex
and then it's on this person to figure
out how to get their dog to stop barking
it just it shouldn't be this girl's
problem to figure out her neighbor's
problem say great you live in an
apartment building figure it out also
something that I love to do because I'm
just like so petty
he's start making some noise of your own
show her what it's night time so baby on
the wall start hanging up some art maybe
just play like a loud video of a dog
watch the morning toast unload
yeah like let her know what it's like
maybe she'll be more considerate if she
understood the pain you're going through
okay hi girls I want to start by saying
thank you for giving me the confidence I
didn't know I needed both of you have
gotten a little work done by dr. Sharon
jay-z and I was so inspired by your
openness and enthusiasm that let it led
me to get my own rhinoplasty procedure
I've wanted it for a long time and what
better time to get it then now I'm
currently so so about that let me do I
want to do something go tomorrow do it
then you have more Life to Live we
learned matters I'm currently in the
process of scheduling the surgery for
myself the recovery time is typically
one to two weeks it's fairly minimal
but I need to wear a nose cast for one
week post-op and expect to be seated
upright the entire time with not a lot
of movement that being said the doctor
recommended I take 1 to 2 days off work
and work from home for the remaining
time oh please me to heal okay work from
home yeah but I've heard actually no
shop unless you get like super invasive
like a classic rhinoplasty is actually
like really easy recovery
I don't but then you see those pictures
the bruising is curved yes but that you
can cover up um the question is how do I
bring this up to my new manager I
recently in the last few weeks got a new
job and my manager is a man about my
dad's age and I don't know his feelings
about plastic surgery in order to
request the paid time off and working
remotely I need to give a reason he
technically doesn't have the power to
deny it but how do I communicate I don't
want him to think it's a taboo or a dumb
reason to take off it's just uncommon at
my company to work remotely so I know
they'll need an actual purpose for it do
I own it without the shame and say that
I'm getting a nose job or should I be
vague and just tell them getting a
surgical procedure will need time to
recover I'm worried the women on my new
team will gossip if they find out about
the procedure although they'll probably
be nosy and gossip about it even if they
don't know what the surgery is for
anyway what do you think should I be
less worried of what they think I don't
want to become off I'm professional
because I want to work from home for a
rhinoplasty we'd love your help on that
sincerely a nosy toaster wow this is a
really interesting situation right
because you could obviously just be like
I'm getting surgery and they can't ask
any questions like but then you'll come
to work after the two days on with the
bruise and who knows so you could like
go to ashley tisdale deviated septum
around right there's two ways here like
own the now as this super it would say
like I just [ __ ] own it say like
[ __ ] I'm getting a nose shot and then
show up the next day a week later with a
brand new nose and honestly you should
get the surgery on a Wednesday take
Thursday Friday off Saturday Sunday
except my Monday comes around like
you're at the best shape you can be
mm-hmm but I still don't think she could
go into work on Monday like that's when
she starts working from home right cuz I
think own it I don't I don't know if I
would own it because I'm not because I
would be ashamed or anything but work is
it's different it's like it's not like
telling your friends or something
I would say that you're having surgery
if they press I would say like deviated
septum so yeah you know medical reason
um
because people the women will probably
realize and then everyone will like be
talking about it so at least own half of
it is my advice and you know if you're a
woman who works in this office and
you're happen to be a toaster I would
really urge you like not to be so petty
and gossip about someone's nose like
it's none of your [ __ ] business and
be like you're just an [ __ ] who's
jealous like if you're talking [ __ ]
about someone to know his job do you
mean yeah I don't know if it's
necessarily talking [ __ ] it's just
noticing I know but still at the end of
the day like I mean I don't work in a
corporate office so I can't really give
good advice but it's like if someone
came in with a nose job like I just
wouldn't be that [ __ ] at the
watercooler like talking about it like
it was something she's insecure about
like [ __ ] off yeah I agree with that you
know but you can't help what other
people know but you say if other people
happen to be toasters like don't talk to
yet okay but it's also like these are
people that you work with they're not
your close personal friends who so who
gives you care yeah but you have to see
them every single day but you know
christmas is coming up do you get time
off for that maybe that's a good time to
do it getting surgery and going back to
work is like the timing is very
precarious Macari it's like I came back
from my chin surgery looking like an
absolute beast on this show so swollen
yeah but it had to be done that's what
running your own business is like that's
true with a scarf around my head like
Ziggy flicker I actually do think about
that often like when I get surgery like
when would I do it also it's for people
who have jobs all that guys on-air
correspondent he's like people in the
view like when do they get boob jobs
right if they get them you know ya know
I think about that often like uh
Savannah Guthrie like are you getting
your lips done if so what right you just
like show up one day with new lips right
and are you swollen
that's like Taylor's trip to the cat's
premiere she does : lip and it kind of
looked like she might have like gotten
punched in the face um because it was
only one side of her lip and it was just
uncommon like if she did get her lips
done when she very well might and good
for her it just didn't look like that so
it's like when your job is being a
public persona like when the [ __ ] do you
get surgery yep Pretender stuff is
actually easier because like she just
pops up here like she can get surgery
any time I just I'm really worried about
us yeah like one by the way we're gonna
have to get breast reductions and lifts
like on the same week yeah and maybe
we'll just take off with into a fatality
everyone like I just kind of want to
pretend I just my breasts are perfect
god-like figure themselves out I know I
know I look I have so much respect for
people like Stassi she said I got a
breast reduction like I think it's like
so brave and because people are so
judgmental and rude and I really do
think it makes a difference for people
who follow you or people who like like
your content or whatever like it's
empowering because a lot of people think
about doing something for their whole
lives they never do it so this girl got
her nose
because you and I spoke about getting em
sculpt done like our chins done like
great that's true I would never like lie
about work that I have done in the
future it's just like also you need it
to be such a big thing like it's the
breast job week of the totes Jackie you
know also can't get away with it that's
the thing and I think it's worse to
pretend like you're hiding it when
everyone knows like when I got my lips
done for the first time I didn't say
anything for two days I want to see if
people were gonna notice and of course
like literally every message I got was
like your lips look different did you
get them done so I never tried to hide
it I just want to see if people are
gonna notice and something so small as
your lips like 1000% like you could not
get away with that and honestly you look
such like you look like more of a loser
trying to hide it I would never try and
hide it but it's like to me like there
has to be an in-between between like
hiding something and making it a huge
[ __ ] spectacle is all you know that's
all we talk about totally you know I
can't I just say wake up one day with
new tips I can't that happen for me yeah
I wouldn't just like pretend like it I
woke up like this but we don't have to
harp on it you know we don't but we can
well we'll cross that bridge when we get
there yeah give us a few years thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast our second-to-last episode
of the year tomorrow is our final
episode where we will be doing a year
recap the top five stories of the year
it's gonna be good stuff so make sure
you tune in to the morning toast
millennium morning show what we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to give this
video a thumbs up comment about how
stunning and smart we are we also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's about it by
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I heard
radio cast box
if you like the merch that were wearing
head over to shop morning choice calm
very limited stock left make sure to get
it before the holidays we love you guys
so much have an amazing day we will see
you tomorrow for our last show of the
year
Wow craziness see you
you